some two thousand kilometers away from
home people in this tiny italian village
have opened up their homes and
businesses to the women and children
fleeing the war in ukraine
on the sixth day since president putin
started this war we decided to leave our
homeland because we were afraid not for
ourselves but for the children for their
future
in a few days they would be without
electricity without gas without water
how can you explain that to them
these two sisters-in-law fled leve
leaving their husbands behind
after three exhausting days of travel
they arrived in the italian town of
belmont in sabina home to around 50
residents
they were welcomed in by giacomo and his
wife patrizia who own a local bed and
breakfast and have put the place on
standby to offer them a home
it seems normal to me maybe it's not the
best in the world
because we're sheltering them with
children but the first thing that came
to my mind is to make this available to
them first we solve their emergency
situation which must be terrible
the two women are among the 58 000
ukrainians who have fled to italy since
the war began
tanya told her daughter that their
escape from war was a trip to visit her
grandmother a friend of the ben and
breakfast owners who also live in the
small italian town
at the beginning she was enthusiastic
but now tanya says she's beginning to
miss her dad
her aunt katya hasn't lost faith and
believes the war will come to an end
soon
we believe in future we will be able to
return home and rebuild a new life
we will renew our economic life we will
rebuild the country our future will be
as peaceful as it was before
but for now they're living every day one
step at a time
far away from home
jillian wolf
al jazeera